[Music]
the bat mom's movie very funny and I
thought I don't know if this is
something it's fun to do or not but in
this movie your character has an
incredible potty mouth curses like a
sailor yes and I was wondering is that a
fun thing to do when you were given
license to swear like that yes because I
have a five and a half year old so I
can't at home you can't swear it oh I
have I've always had a terrible potty
mouth
I mean you yes in real life real life
I'm horrible like the other actresses
would always be like Jesus what is
coming out of your mouth man like you
better rein it in freak right and I when
I was five years old I'm gonna say a
real a real bad one but they're gonna
blur that's what you said when you were
five I learned this in nursery school my
mom said I came home and I said sucker
tell me more about this school well cuz
what kind of school was this I mean come
on manners like the 70s you know anyway
I don't care if it was the 70s like I
wait turn those by at them you know
ourselves and they go into the grocery
store right like crack a window for kids
so my mom said that I just like after
that like I couldn't stop I just and she
said okay Christina you can say all this
at home but that's it you can say it as
much as you want at home but that's it
you more outside you are not allowed to
say that so that was the rule that's so
girl that's so when you were home I can
you were like this is good sucking
breath you mom that was awesome yeah
yeah that was how it we world my house
you were like a little Gordon Ramsay
yeah exactly
you know you know we try not we don't
cuss in front of Sadie obviously Oh
Sadie your daughter is how old she's
five and a half she's five so there's no
swearing in front of her no but the
other day Oh City the other day she was
in the bathroom and she like hit her
knee when she was coming out I heard a
go oh [ __ ]
and I said I said what's that now she
goes mmm yeah and then she just walked
away
someone's been cussing in front of my
kid yeah of course they've got a couple
kinds of stuff right now or more
appropriately some suckers
[Applause]
[Laughter]
settle down my my kids I have very nice
kids and our son thought that he knew
like two years ago he was when he was
like I don't he's seven or something he
thought that he learned what the F word
was and he said I know what the F word
is so we were like oh man someone told
him the F word he was like yeah and I
said to him what's the F word and he
said it's funk thought the F word was
funk and so we my wife and I were like
why fight each other one yes that's very
very bad don't use that word so we
thought okay we're off the hook he won't
be asking anyone what's the F word I
think it's funk
and then that Bruno Mars song came out
uptown funk right and my son was like
but where does sound like a thousand
times no no no no no hey and he was
wondering like why are all the people at
school dancing to that
you